Jen is with us in Philadelphia
hi Jen welcome to the Dave Ramsey show
hi thanks for taking my call
sure I wanted to call because my father
has trouble with gambling and he had
gotten a little bit of an inherence from
my grandmother after she passed about
11,000 and he gambled it all away and
he's about to come into a larger sum of
inheritance from her after her house
sells about 90,000 and I wanted to see
what you thought about either being a
cosigner on some kind of account with
him so he can't get to it and Gamble it
away or have it in my name and then me
kind of be the guardian over it and hold
on to it until he's into retirement and
give it to him at that point it's not a
cosigner you don't want to be a cosigner
with us going anything because it could
opening up the liability for other stuff
he does so you don't want that it might
be is he willing to let you control this
money for his benefit he's kind of in a
position my that's my grandmother had
passed my uncle was stay over everything
and then he had passed and now his wife
is over a state of everything and he my
uncle who passed originally had wanted
me to get the money and not my father
because of a gambling problem I would
like him to have something going into
retirement that was not your uncle's
option yeah
the executor of the estate does not get
to change the terms of the will because
the air is misbehaving okay they cannot
give the money to you unless it was
dictated to you in the will that would
be illegal your aunt is getting ready to
get herself in a mess if your dad
decided to press charges it's like
stealing $90,000 from him even though I
said even though it's in his best
interest so unless the terms of the will
were changed or the court if a judge if
she goes before the judge as the
executrix of the estate and says this
guy is going to gamble this away I
recommend
moving into her into his daughter's name
managed for his good if the judge
dictates that then your aunt would be
safe but your aunt cannot just write you
the check because she doesn't like the
situation that's straight-up illegal
okay
would be the best way to handle it
either have to get the judge to dictate
this or your dad has to do it willingly
if he's willing to if he's willing to
then you need to see an attorney and
spend about a thousand dollars on legal
fees and have a trust set up and your
dad is the beneficiary of the trust and
you are the trustee you know the trustee
has all the control the beneficiary
receives all the benefits and so
anything good that comes off of the
money does not go to you it goes to him
but you are in charge of the money for
his benefit okay as if he were a child
who had inherited this money and you
were managing it for a child until they
became you know in this case I might say
if he was dry for 60 months and he
wanted to get control of his own money
that'd be fine but I'd want five years
of dry if I were him and if I were you
his gambling addiction is really
prevalent right now yeah as he will do
this voluntarily I think it's possible I
know he knows that he has trouble with
it 50/50 I think I think it's it's
possible yeah and he doesn't have any
retirement so I mean if you can talk any
talk him into it it is a great act of
love on your part but it needs to be set
up as a trust with an attorney doing the
trust and the turn he's the beneficiary
you're the trustee do you understand
that and the terms of the trust are
however he wants and you want to manage
this money for his benefit but the money
cannot be given to you against his will
unless a judge says so you both you all
will get yourself in a mess because all
he's got to do is hire an attorney and
smack all of you in the next week and he
would win because you do not have the
right to just change the terms of a will
or an estate plan because you don't like
the heirs
otherwise nobody'd ever get any money